on September 21st in Lake Odessa
Michigan Joanne Jacobson was canvassing
against a pro-abortion ballot
proposition that was that was up for a
vote and so she was going around
neighborhoods as a lot of campaigners do
uh expressing her views and persuading
her fellow citizens and was all going
just fine until she got to one home the
Harvey residents where the woman Mrs
Harvey instantly became very very
hostile was clearly very supportive of
abortion and I suppose I suppose Mrs
Harvey is entitled to her opinions but
then what happened is Mrs Harvey's
husband came out with a gun with a
loaded gun
and shot Joanne Jacobson Joanne is 84
years old 120 pounds retired nurse not
someone you would say is presenting a
particular physical threat to you or
your family
shot and this story has received
basically no coverage anywhere in the
establishment media because it
contradicts the pro-abortion narratives
that they're all trying to sell so we
think that it is only right and just and
fair to have a Joanne on with her lawyer
attorney Steve Coleman to to just
explain what happened Joanne thank you
so much for coming on the show I'm so
sorry to hear about what happened to you
well thank you for having me
I I would say I'm I'm so sorry to hear
what happened to you I'm so happy to
hear that you escaped obviously the
situation could have gone way
differently and you would not be sitting
here talking about this today so just if
you wouldn't mind what happened
you mean Steph from the beginning please
yeah okay well I went to the door or I
told her why I was being there and she
identified herself as being Mrs Harvey
and immediately when I mentioned
proposal three and voting no she got
very angry antagonistic and said that no
she was gonna vote no on it and I said
to her I kept calm I didn't raise my
voice and I said did she know that it
was going to amend the State
Constitution and she just said she
didn't care she was in a vote no and
then she proceeded to tell me that she
had had a tubal pregnancy
and I said to her I said well
there's always been an exception for the
life of the mother because in this
situation that's what happens they have
to take the baby because it's not going
to be able to mature in the fallopian
tube and so um
you know
I I said I told her again a second time
and I don't think that she understood
what I was saying about it it's an
exception to the life of the mother and
obviously her life was in danger
well she she keeps yelling and she says
well I don't want this to happen to
anybody else and I can't even have a
chance to explain to her that yes this
is going to happen to somebody else
medicine doesn't know doesn't know
to my knowledge when a mother is going
to have an ectopic pregnancy there's
nothing that they can do to stop it
and um
so she that immediately says you don't
have a right to be here and get off my
property
to which I replied I'm going so I got
down the steps through three or four
steps to get up to the port
um
got on the sidewalk I'm carrying a
clipboard because I have a list of homes
that I'm going to go visit
and they're telling me I had my umbrella
because it was raining that day I
couldn't tell the police for sure if I
had the umbrella or not
so I'm hanging onto my clipboard and my
umbrella
and it's a long sidewalk it's not like
the city it's a long sidewalk from the
home
to the driveway 50 to 60 feet
and so I'm about 12 15 feet down on the
sidewalk and she's behind me yelling so
she's she's following you as you walk
away well yeah I mean she's off the
porch she's on right at the bottom of
the steps
and she's on her cell phone and she's
yelling at me constantly I don't
remember everything that she yelled but
she was yelling get off my property
and so I kept going in
as I'm walking out of the corner of my
eye
I saw that there was a man there was a
barn on the on the property there was a
man walking alongside the barn
didn't think anything of it he didn't
come up and talk to me but please ask me
well was he carrying a gun I can't tell
you if he was carrying a gun or not
um
you didn't come and talk to me you went
around the back of me and I'm just
assuming he's going up to his home
really didn't think a thing of it keep
walking and
um get me on my clipboard and my
umbrella they told me I had the umbrella
and um
she's yelling constantly behind me
you know get off my property
and then at some point she's all of a
sudden she's alongside of me I'm on the
sidewalk and she's in the grass
but five or six feet away from me
and I and I I looked up for some reason
and
the police said that there were two
shots
I had only heard one shot
so I'm thinking what made me look up
is the fact I do have some caring
problem
that I heard something
didn't recognize it as being a gunshot
and then so I'm turning sideways and
looking and I see the man is standing
next to her
in the grass
and as soon as I realized he was
standing there I I know the first thing
I noticed was he had this gun long
barrel gun
and by the time
just a matter of seconds it's like
I heard the shot and I felt this pain
and I thought oh he shipped me in the
back because I had intense pain in the
back
and
they didn't say anything and I didn't
think I said anything but I've been told
she evidently was taping what was
happening
that I said did he shoot me I thought I
just said it to myself
you didn't say anything she didn't say
anything and that was all I said and I
started walking to my car
as I because I almost at the end of the
sidewalk so I'm pretty much closer to my
car
I get I open up the door and I'm
thinking am I going to be able to drive
I don't know how badly I was hurt
and so I didn't feel dizzy or faint or
no any other symptoms other than pain
so I thought well I think I can get in
the car and drive and so I didn't call
9-1-1
getting ready to get behind the wheel
and I happened to look through the
windshield of the car and they're both
still standing there
and I told the cop I said for a fleeting
second I thought this guy's gonna shoot
me again he's going to shoot right
through the window
well fortunately he didn't I get in the
car he didn't gear back up get on the
road
and think what am I going to do I
thought well I've got to tell the police
so I drove to the police station in Lake
Odessa
probably be about three miles or so
I get there and the village manager
comes out and he says what can I do for
you and I said I think I've been shot
and shot he said and I said I turned
around I said can you see anything
and she had up here on my shoulder of
course I can't see it
and he immediately said to me he's the
go sit down on that couch over there and
the next thing I know I'm surrounded by
about five or six people and they're
wanting to take off my top and they're
telling me no no no don't move keep your
back straight and they're putting
they're rolling me and putting me on a
board and before I do it I'm in the
ambulance and I'm on the way to the
emergency room right now head on over to
ring.com Knowles the fall is just a
magical wonderful time of the year and
it's very very busy the kids are back at
school you got to go pick them up at the
dance recital you got to go get them
from after school you maybe you're
traveling you got the holidays coming up
you got to Jet out to go get your latest
pumpkin spice latte okay people are
really really busy you're in and out of
the house you want to make sure your
home is safe that's why you need ring
ring yes they've got the video doorbell
you see and speak to whoever is on your
doorstep no matter where you are in the
home at the office on the other side of
the world ring also has a powerful home
security system that's called ring alarm
and then ring took it up another notch
even you're not just going to protect
your doors and your windows and your
physical home they've got ring alarm Pro
GoPro be a pro just like me CNET calls
ring alarm Pro a giant leap for home
security right now head on over to
ring.com these are the guys that I trust
find out how you can live a little more
stress-free this season with a ring
product that is right for you that is
ring.com
Knowles so the shot landed it was in
your back it was in your shoulder it was
because because of my turning sideways
it hit the right the top of my right
shoulder and exited out my back
up in the thoracic area of the spine
and I was told by the doctors that I was
one lucky person because it just
narrowly missed my spine
um fortunate otherwise the reason I
could drive is because it didn't get any
major vessels and it didn't hit the bone
so that's why I was able to safely I
didn't think I was going to endanger
myself or you know anybody else on the
road to get behind the car and and drive
to the police station Joanne I have to
tell you there are some times when I
stub my toe and I feel that I can't
drive so the fact that you were able to
drive after being shot is
extraordinarily impressive and thank God
that the people at the police station
were able to say sit down we're taking
you to the emergency room we're going to
treat you
obviously both of these people should be
in prison I'm not a uh I'm not a lawyer
I don't I I I'm not a cop I don't work
for the justice department but it would
seem clear to me that if two people
shoot a pro-life canvasser an 84 year
old pro-life Canvas OR 120 pounds
soaking wet walking to her car these
people should be arrested and in jail so
are they in jail
they are he is arrested he's not on bond
is that of course he's out on bond of
course they've only charged the husband
right now they charged him with a
four-year felony and two misdemeanors so
he was charged and arraigned and he got
a ten thousand dollar bond that he
posted and so he's out right now
a four-year felony he shot an 84 year
old woman on his property for for doing
something that is perfectly legal by the
way to go around in canvas and and
campaign and persuade your fellow
citizens that's as American as apple pie
four-year felony
I realize yeah yeah we had obviously
hoped for a much uh stricter charge but
uh the prosecutor we spoke to the
prosecutor and and he said the guy
didn't have any any criminal record and
there were some other mitigating factors
and he just thought that that was all he
could do and so unfortunately our hands
are tied it's his choice and so that's
what he charged Steve I don't have a
criminal record either I think if I shot
an 84 year old woman on my property as
she was walking to her car I I suspect
that not only would I be charged with
more than a four-year felony I would
deserve to be charged for with a lot
more
so part of the issue is that his defense
at least is that it was an accident he
said that uh Joanne was swinging around
her clipboard now I don't know how
swinging around a clipboard is a lethal
danger or something that gives rise to
you shooting someone but he said she was
swinging her on her clipboard we
obviously vehemently disagree with that
and he said he tried to knock her
clipboard down with with his gun and it
accidentally went off that's his story
at least and so all right he's sorry
Steve I got to stop you there so he's
saying it's an accident that he went and
got his loaded rifle to terrorize an 84
year old woman walking to her car who
may or may not have moved her clipboard
around and so you know the normal way to
to lower a clipboard is to take a loaded
rifle barrel first and and what try to
nudge it that's just so it it's so
Preposterous that if a woman hadn't been
shot as a result of it I would be
laughing right now
well it's ridiculous there's two big
things that really just dispel what he's
saying first he fired a warning shot so
he knew the gun was loaded he can't say
oh I didn't know there were bullets in
there I didn't know it could fire he
acknowledged I fired a warning shot and
they have proof that it hit a tree so he
knew the gun was loaded so he can't say
he didn't know that and second if
someone truly accidentally you know
let's let's say for a second that he's
right let's say it was a total accident
he had total lapse of judgment let's
give him the benefit of the doubt for
just one second let's say that that's
true is that a normal response how they
acted after he shot someone I would
think if I accidentally shot someone the
first response would be oh my goodness
I'm so sorry I didn't mean it let me
call an ambulance for you I didn't know
I'm so sorry did they do any of that no
are you afraid you might be facing some
charges
it's always possible I mean you know I
shot somebody yeah
and it was an accident they shot her and
said nothing and just watched her hand
her back to her car and go get help that
doesn't that's not how someone behaves
after they accidentally shoot someone
this is so outrageous I usually come
down on the side of oh let's give people
the benefit of the doubt let's be
merciful let's just go you know let's
show Grace where but it's just every
single step of the way
I don't I don't see how you can
interpret any of these events in any
light other than this lunatic had a fit
of anger and shot an 84 year old woman
so totally agree so if you don't mind my
asking who's the prosecutor
uh it's the Ionia County prosecutor ioni
County prosecutor
okay I think
you know for people who are watching
this right now and listening to this if
you're if you're in the county if you're
in the state or if you're not in the
county and not in the state I would I
would certainly call the prosecutor's
office I would certainly call your
Congressman I would certainly call your
Senator this is such a horrific
miscarriage of Justice also because you
know I mean Joanne I I obviously share
your pro-life sympathies and point of
view and you just know right now the
Department of Justice all the way at the
federal level is is arresting pro-lifers
for not not only for minor infractions
of the law but for completely bogus
alleged minor infractions of the law
that actually haven't taken place and
we've seen these stories increasing in
recent weeks I've covered a lot of them
on my show and so you know if the
situation were reversed here they would
absolutely be throwing the book at the
pro-life or they already are doing that
and I just it's just it's just such a
heinous miscarriage of Justice because a
nice 84 year old woman is going around
to persuade her fellow citizens that
maybe we shouldn't kill us as many
babies that she gets shot and the
prosecutor does effectively nothing
about it
yeah I I think that
they're being influenced by what's being
shut out there the fact I think they're
the rhetoric is that they're telling
women that if we ban abortion in the
state women are going to die
and they're using this particular
situation the uh you know the ectopic
pregnancies
and they're claiming that the
abortionist if if we ban abortion the
abortionist will get arrested if he
takes the baby out it's never been
considered an abortion
in that case but that's the message that
these I think this woman probably is
hearing also of course and likewise the
man and of course what what our
president is saying and you know about I
understand he called me a right-wing nut
or something I don't know where but I've
heard this and so yeah it's I blame
Biden and the Democrat Party for the
rhetoric author right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 the labor Department's
Consumer Price Index which catalogs the
cost of goods Services food and rent
Rose 0.4 percent over the month of
August double what many economists had
anticipated perhaps worse core inflation
which excludes food and gas prices so
the highest increase last month that
it's seen since August of 1982. what is
the current Administration doing to
quell that surge of inflation
spending more taxpayer dollars of course
don't bury your head in the sand while
your savings deplete diversify into gold
with Birch gold today text Knowles kwles
to 98 98 98 and Birch gold will send you
a free info kit on protecting your
savings with gold in a tax sheltered
account the experts over at Birch gold
have almost 20 years of experience in
converting IRAs and 401ks into precious
metals IRAs with an A plus rating from
the Better Business Bureau countless
five-star reviews and thousands of
satisfied customers why have you not
checked them out yet gold has always
been your best hedge against inflation
head on over right now to Birch gold you
text Knowles Canon wlas 298 9898 and
Birch gold will send you a free info kit
on diversifying into gold tax-free take
the necessary steps to hedge against
inflation today protect your hard-earned
money get your free info kit by texting
Knowles kwles to 989-898
now I suppose it's to be expected that
someone who would be so opposed to a
pro-life canvasser would very nearly
kill that that person in a sort of fit
of anger uh on the topic of this ballot
proposition do you have any sense of
where it stands right now you say
there's a lot of misinformation there
about it how do you think it's going to
turn out
I I can't say I I really don't know
since I've been kind of you know
secluded for a couple of weeks right
yeah I haven't heard anything it's it's
going to be a tough one because of how
they've used Orwell to rephrase it
they've they've labeled it the
reproductive Freedom initiative and who
could be against that right you know
right and so I think most voters they
just hear that name and they're like oh
that sounds good I think it'd be for
that and but they don't realize what it
actually does so what it actually says
and so one of the things that we've done
we're helping Joanne but we have the
Great Lakes Justice Center which is our
organization here in Michigan and so we
put out issue briefs and fact sheets
just explaining what it would do to try
to inform the public on what it would
truly do in Michigan and how awful it
would be and how broad it would truly be
interpreted by the courts um the recent
polls that we've seen right now are
about 61 percent are in favor and so
we're very concerned that it's going to
go through and and the worst part is is
one in three Republicans here say
they're they're for it and I certainly
hope that's just because they don't know
what it truly is
right well when you label something you
know the freedom and candy and puppies
act then you know of course everybody
says that they're for it regardless of
what is in the bill Joanne you mentioned
you've been sort of uh taking it easy
for the last couple of weeks how is your
recovery going
yeah the doctor told me it would because
of my age of course it's going to take a
long time to heal
um
the wound here is healed but the one on
the back is is bigger and I it's taking
longer to heal
so I can't take showers yeah don't want
to get any water down in into the egg so
I have to worry about infection
but that seems not to be the case so far
thank goodness well that that's
wonderful I mean I think even if you
know a 25 year old were shot through the
shoulder you know that would be a
difficult recovery and so of course if
you're if you're 84 that's going to take
longer has has the the man or the this
wife the Harvey family have they reached
out at all have they sent flowers have
they said sorry we shot you
no no they have not wow one interesting
thing that happened though was uh
shortly after it happened a few days
after it happened uh one of the local TV
stations heard about it and went to the
residence and they went on camera and Mr
Harvey talked to him and acknowledged on
camera yeah I shot her and she's got
this clipboard she's waving around I'm
thinking she's going to smash Sharon
with it so without thinking I went to
Club it away with the rifle and my
finger was still in the trigger card and
it went off and it went off it hit it
about in here
and so obviously he hadn't been talking
to an attorney at that point I would
assume but we have on video basically
his confession that he shot her and so
at least that part of it we've got
lockdown is there any hope that the
prosecutor could change his mind here
it's just such a a gross miscarriage of
Justice or is it is this this it he'll
at the very most get a slap on the wrist
and then it sends a message to all the
other abortion Fanatics that yes it's
open season on pro-life activists
exactly right it's possible but unlikely
wow wow well I I hope if there is any
possibility at all that uh these charges
could be brought up even I don't know to
even to 20 of what they ought to be that
that really I hope that there's enough
political pressure from this
Prosecutor's constituents and from other
people around the state uh who who can
uh push for that and Joanne obviously
wishing you the the strongest recovery
that you can possibly have is there uh
is there any place I can direct our
listeners to go to to support uh your
work any sort of legal efforts uh Steve
you mentioned the legal center that is
fighting on behalf of these sorts of
causes
yeah if anyone's interested please go to
Great Lakes Justice Center or it's
greatlakesjc.org
and right on there we have our fact
sheet and issue briefs about proposal
three if people want more information or
they also have Michigan Right to Life
that's a great site too to learn more
information Great Lakes Justice Center
that's wonderful and Joanne are there
are there people you know coming over
bringing you food or anything or sort of
taking care of you
yes outpouring for my pro for life
friends yes
oh good I'm very glad to hear that you
certainly I listen to call me
old-fashioned I think at the age of 84
people ought to be uh taking care of uh
you know you just generally but
especially when you're recovering from
being shot by an insane pro-abortion
lunatic I think you know a couple of
casseroles to the house would be a
certainly a very nice thing to do uh
yeah muffin
very appreciative uh that well that's
wonderful and I got it I gotta tell you
Joanne I would be looking a lot worse if
I were in your position even at my age
of 32 I think you uh you put uh lady
yeah I think you put lady Thatcher to
shame frankly I think you are one tough
lady Joanne so it's wonderful and thank
you for standing up for the truth and
Having the courage to go out and and
canvas and persuade your fellow citizens
and and risk the dangers that come not
just from you know we people worry about
being canceled on social media or being
censored but you're facing actual
physical risk and doing it it's just
doing doing God's work Joanne wonderful
wonderful stuff and thank you so much
for coming on the show
thanks for letting me tell my story
thanks for having us we appreciate it
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]